well hello everybody and thanks for
joining us today on the h3 podcast
joined by the wonderful Jack Black and
Kyle Gass yes of tenacious d of whom we
are all we all love and appreciate
today's episode is sponsored by me
Indies Vince ero Robin Hood and mint
mobile now you guys are here I can hear
myself Dan but that's okay do you guys
have a new animated series
post-apocalyptic that is on YouTube
right now for free
yeah why isn't everyone closing this and
watching that well listen to what they
have to say I think it's kind of hard to
find but I'm an old man I think the best
way to find the full movie
post-apocalyptic is to go to tenacious d
calm and just click on it there for free
and if you also go to tenacious d comm
you can find out that these two
wonderful men are touring all throughout
this month so grab some tickets and
catch the D live the best one to see of
all the shows were playing is December
30th in Las Vegas we're doing something
very special I guess I can't say what
we're doing there but that's the one if
you can you should get on a plane and
fly to see Tenacious D in Las Vegas on
30 a lot of people are gravitating
towards our New Year's Eve show in Las
Vegas and that's the natural show but
the good show has nothing to do with
tickets laughs Wow
well and also variety for your
consideration
what's an HD did you guys see that
though picture of I don't know who put
that in there well really was
I watched and loved so much this this is
it a movie our show because it's six
parts and then you've got it all
together in one slot so do you think of
it as a movie or a show well we have
found that the best delivery system is
actually on a big screen in a movie
theater mm-hmm and just seeing it all at
once
sharing it with the fellow fans and so
it's um it's more of a movie so I we
didn't know we I think we accidentally
made a movie when we were making little
episodes you're making little five to
ten minute episodes and then when we got
when we got to the sixth episode the
finale we realized if we took away the
intro outro and and ran them as one
movie it actually played the best so
yeah we think of it in a lot of
different ways it's an album it's a TV
show it's a movie it could be a Broadway
play good it is yeah well the live show
is very rock opera ask presentation of
the oh yeah sounds super fun yeah yeah
now thinking maybe one up and you know
Bruce Springsteen's on Broadway right
now doing his show I don't think he has
any magic he's the singer-songwriter so
I thought why don't we just you know
well you I think you're kidding but I
would I would watch the heck out of a
post-apocalyptic Broadway show yeah well
you know part of reason why we did part
of reason part of the reason why we did
post-apocalyptic we were jealous of Book
of Mormon our arch enemies did this
incredibly funny mm-hmm musical comedy
if you get a chance to see it it's
probably playing near your town now
mm-hmm
super raunchy politically incorrect
Broadway musical and we were like yeah
we want to party in that sphere mmm
genre robble you yeah the dramas well
there's isn't really a rock opera
yeah you've true there's actually
classical classic it was Broadway so
it was so hard to see and I was living
in Israel at the time and there was so
much hubbub about it I really wanted to
see it and I'm the only thing I was able
to find was a gentleman recording it on
his cell phone and I have to say I don't
remember much but I think it was good
yeah we should still like yeah we should
yeah but so you guys did everything on
this and it's a very unique style you've
got it's a cartoon but it's what looks
like one frame every 10 seconds so you
guys kind of which I find charming it's
not like I wouldn't consider it like
it's it's just a style and I think it's
very charming was this something like a
style that you guys chose for or was it
kind of an expedient thing well at first
we were thinking this is we're just
gonna do a real rough version of what
our fully animated show would be you
know we were making our Rick and Morty
basically and nobody wanted it on any of
the network so then we were like we're
gonna just do it our way and it was just
the cheapest way to do it right yes but
at the end of the day it ended up being
in a way funnier than it is charming
there yeah and there wasn't any point
where I was like oh I wish I had more
frames right cuz you get it you totally
go and I mean this I totally understand
as I watch that robot vagina suck and
swirl on that cough like cellular alert
in a way it makes it rather Lorna
graphic well it's just frame I was
dubbed up
I never go I never wanted to [ __ ] a
robot before I watched you guys no wait
when we're done with this youtube series
we're gonna like release it on Apple TV
but then Apple was like well wait a
second you have to get a rating from the
ratings board the MPAA ratings good luck
and we're like fine we went to the MPAA
we paid them the thousand bucks or
whatever it cost to get the thing and
then they said this is nc-17 and it
cannot be shown anywhere
drawing of a penis and it's like a badly
drawn drawing of it's not like real
photo realistic no and at the end of the
day I think it's like the sweetest
pornography you've ever seen it's like
it's got a it's got a real message of
love it's not coming from a place of
exploitation absolutely no exploit not
at all everyone is enjoying themselves
there is I mean it's there's a scene of
well the robot does put a finger in the
butt yeah and also spoiler alert take
the balls and guys the penis into the
vagina
oh but I had I was I was like wow well
anyway it's it's very educational it is
that's true it saves you a conversation
about the birds and the bees if you want
to just show parents well you guys you
guys gave a warning beforehand but it's
true I noticed the only show on YouTube
you've got these six episodes in the
movie the only one that is an
age-restricted is the first episode and
I don't know if you guys know about how
YouTube works but when a video gets
age-restricted they share it less yeah
oh oh we know yeah all too well well I
think there's BOTS flying around looking
for shapes of not just that they don't
share it's like it's impossible to find
the full movie if you type in tenacious
d post-apocalyptic full movie
it still doesn't come up yeah and if
you're not signed in you can't watch it
oh that's okay but I just want people to
be able to find that's why I'm only
telling people to go to the Y but if you
go to the channel you'll see it all
there but yeah YouTube does it they bury
stuff they they'll just bury it because
they're so afraid of it harming their
platform and scaring advertisers away
but it's just a little what about this
for promotion though the show YouTube
didn't watch well I'm telling you you
you're gonna watch this robot swirl is
vagina around a [ __ ] and you'll be like
damn I can't wait for the future yeah I
mean the future is a gun I think there
already are robots they're talking about
robots and brothels now so I heard of a
sec
doll bra yeah yes but I don't know that
there's mechanics in the vagina because
the sloppy plastic God is just around
the corner though really appealing now
would you guys [ __ ] a robot that had
like a superb edge I must admit
in my youth I think there might have
been a dull experience tell me about
that more well I might have continued in
the early days of experimentation yeah
when you want to practice I think that
the dolls can be a great educational
tool
I fully first of all no judgment on my
side I mean I put at that age you put
your dick in just about anything yeah I
mean tell me about what did the doll
look like kind of like yeah where did
you get it where do you get those
because do you have to be of age or do
you get those at a sex shop it there
might have been some shoplifting
involved I don't think I should go in
there might have been a crazy night out
LA yeah I might have been like nineteen
years old so it's like wait that's a
little old for for needing a doll well
no there's no age limit on when you need
a doll well apparently you're not you
can't even buy it until you're 18 so the
people that need it the most don't have
access to it right yeah in fact I think
maybe the target audience is a men in
their 40s for the doll that could be I'm
too old for that I think I just depended
on a large pillow vivid imagination yeah
I have a guy I want to expand on this
further your show and I don't know it's
good I'm taking it too far but if you
[ __ ] a robot sex at all is it cheating
oh if you're married and you have such a
thing you know all I want is a vagina it
can swirl and suck and do all them do
everything but I mean it's just a robot
is that she
I think it depends on the the the
secrecy of the act
yeah what if like maybe maybe you're
going on the road to do a job and your
wife would actually give you a doll or
like a little a little flashlight
something that would fit in the isn't a
flashlight basically a sex robot well
it's not a robot but it is a sex flesh
like what do you think wow there's a lot
there well here this one is not very
graphic so let me show you this one
Christ's sake it's on Amazon here I've
been wasting my time with my hand this
all these years
well so so let's start here ela is a
fleshlight infidelity so here this is a
fleshlight usually shaped more like a
vagina but I don't want to think you can
see in there oh but it's a basically and
I love that they make it look like a
flat like a flashlight of all things
like put your dick in this flashlight
what sphere does it light up
there's no oh wow please don't be a
penis okay we better know seems like the
light could create some warmth mmm so
can I use a flashlight
ela without consulting with you um I
guess it'd just be a little weird yeah
if you did okay right so if it doesn't
have a face it's not cheating
I think the parameters just have to be
decided on take that oh yeah but what's
the flashlight in masturbating yeah I'm
sorry to include you guys on this
conversation it's alright masturbation
right well maybe yeah is masturbation
cheating yeah no no no especially if
you're like oh get out of here and go
masturbate yeah you don't want to see
that me a break exactly
I think I was reading though he is
important that you should master bait
together though you should be not all
the time well nobody comfortable with
eye contact that was a Howard Stern
interview I heard that and Ringo claimed
he wasn't there for that session people
made such a big scoop out of it well
it's funny besides that it's funny but
like people started trying to draw the
conclusion that they were like lovers
and all this you know it's just a couple
dudes jerking off in the dark I mean
right yes yeah and maybe yeah maybe
that's why they kicked out the drummer
is they didn't like the way he
masturbated all the ladies though he was
an American and apparently he was very
good-looking
is he still available for drumming you
know we got we got we got yeah we got
great drummer so you guys did the voice
the art the music the writing this is
your baby post-apocalyptic yeah you're
saying tour-de-force I was like that was
coming next tour des fleurs and who was
the art director because there is a very
distinct art style throughout art
direction and all our times man I
actually tried to draw a cell just to
show Jack what it would be like if he
wasn't drawing it and it was really bad
did you actually try it I did draw it
but we got a you know how probably - we
got a colorist mmm who is a amazing
michael molina to do all the color with
his computer and yeah we were gonna hand
over the reins to some other animator
and an artist at some point but that was
back when we had dreams of having a
netflix or HBO series and then we were
like
it's better this way anyway he were
laughing so but head isn't well drawn no
it's great its yeah I wanted someone
there to draw beavis and butt-head there
look anime style it's like so nobody
wanted this show I mean I find that pure
insanity well I see somebody like ya was
interested whoa no none of the major
players but were you guys uncompromising
on the penis and set like very great
yeah dots
no we we presented what we wanted to put
on the air we weren't saying hey we want
to do something like this we were like
we want one did they want you yeah and
no one wanted to go with us down that
that crazy half but in a way we were
kind of glad about that because it gave
us an opportunity to really go did seem
kind of liberating like yeah no it's
just kind of a fun project with your
friends exactly how we wanted to make it
well I loved it and I urge everyone to
go watch it now you guys do guys watch
YouTube I know
oh really I do could you do like well
Mike oh yeah I'm sorry oh thank you well
I'll just go down strange wormholes as
we call them like I wonder if Thin Lizzy
played a live concert in the UK in 74 or
something and I'll just find myself
watching old concerts or any ball I mean
those were Leeds and YouTube's kind of
brilliant at leading you to the next oh
yeah oh that's yeah I know prettier than
we do yeah yeah so I find it yeah
eminently entertaining that's great I
guess most people don't watch it like I
do well there's different there's
different worlds there's people that
like watch YouTube for the personality
or I guess I don't know what to say
there's people that produce content on
YouTube and then there's I think a lot
of people like you who use it just
because everything's on YouTube because
everything's watched
you can watch music you can watch bands
and then you just go down this crazy
rabbit hole of like endless content so
there's two types of people and I guess
you're very much though well and there's
the endless I mean how do I play of
something on guitars right yeah Wow
Jack do you use I go on the youtubes
mainly to like figure out how to make
potato latkes yeah what you'll be doing
today I'm having some family over this
evening for a Hanukkah celebration I've
never made the potato latkes somebody
else in the family would be in charge of
those so this film how did you get stuck
with latke duty this year it's you know
it's sad but my mom used to make the lot
I'm sorry for yeah but yeah so I think
it's gonna take a village we're all
gonna I'm gonna have I have a bunch of
graders and a pile of potatoes
well latkes is a good start I think
latkes is a like poker as they say it
takes a day to learn a lifetime to
master yeah so you will be a latke kings
so you're always just one YouTube video
away from making the perfect latke
that's true that's my this day in a
whole thing of course you say the prayer
are you ready for it
are you kidding me tell me if I do this
correctly is rye in this is the hard
part
I share krishana babies for time the
Teva new shell ha ha that's impressive
[Music]
[Applause]
rabbi black using my soothes the savage
beasts do you know any other Hebrew
prayers because I am just a modern well
you know I think that was written back
in the I was 18 Oh pretty sure Jesus
they had him in a chair and they were
doing the whole the King you actually
pronounced everything correct to Israel
here especially we don't say like Shalom
how do you say thank you and neighbor
means so many things you re a lot of us
were surprised to learn that you're
Jewish I don't know why yeah but that
came to as a surprise to a lot of us but
you your father was born a Jew now oh my
father was it my father was born
Protestant right my mother was born a
Jew which makes me full Jew according to
the Jews I I'm not I'm not questioning
your you and the idea is we know where
you came from mom yeah because we have
witnesses so true I never thought of it
like that you came out of that vagina
you are yes we did we don't have DNA
right is that the best show ever when
they start breakdancing [ __ ] in front of
the baby but yours that I love it I love
it so much but your story is unusual
because usually I find that it's the
male
or the female that converts to Judaism
but your dad converted to Judaism right
yeah I find that fascinating well it
wasn't just because he loved my mom but
also because he was into Judaism Wow but
since they divorced he is now no longer
practicing Jew he drunk yeah it's like
when you lose certain friends in a
divorce you lost he loved ya so so I was
raised you I got my bar mitzvah and then
I immediately sort of bailed you taking
the whole enterprise exactly me but a
lot of your back to the Bar Mitzvah and
then they'll stick around till 16 or let
you stay around for the confirmation no
hearings or whatever it is that yeah I
later I booked it at 13 I don't know
what the customer you are then
officially adult well you get the check
you got your chatter right I did not get
the big payday that I looked at after
that's the forgot one socks and an in
television cartridge well somebody got
the money Oh somebody and a lot of times
the parents will be like thank you
repaying all those years of Torah school
because I know my parents got thousands
and all they bought me and I was
grateful at the time but in retrospect
I'm like holy [ __ ] they embezzled my bar
mitzvah money this is a yeah I'm calling
you guys out okay all I got was a 1064
and I know they got like 10 G's in 64
see I'm a little older than you because
Nintendo wasn't even out in 1982 when I
got my bar mitzvah so you got socks yeah
a man in television cartridge it was it
was a sad it was a celebration because
as you say I no longer had to go to
Hebrew school yes which was additional
school I had school and I had to go at
work you go in the evening what would do
that well it's doesn't understand your
life you didn't have to think about
extra Judaism yeah exactly she doesn't
understand what US American Jews have
been angry brew and and she doesn't
understand that we just learned the
Hebrew so we couldn't do the Bar Mitzvah
and that none of us even know what the
eff were talking about
yeah that's pretty weird I still have a
couple words Shalom abba-abba-abba EEMA
mohnish and aha la la Ossa that's the
best Passover - tonight it's just some
lyrics from a song I don't even know
that well my favorite if you guys want
something to take away from this is uh
Baruch Hashem which means nobody's like
this you're like days right this is live
we can't go back bees rot Hashem which
means it's like what gods hell with
God's help but let's say oh you're going
on tour that's cool you'll say it bears
like to share like what I like like yes
but let's not that's not good over our
skis yeah but what I like about it is
when you use it and very like trivial
things like well I'm gonna take I gotta
go take a sham God's help you know
that's a little humorous just thinking
about the prayer Baraka Todd and I it's
blessed our God King of the universe you
could use that and every day like yeah
Big Mac king of the universe I don't
know that might not work yeah reminded
me of Flash king of the impossible
yeah oh that makes me think I need to
see that Queen movie huge fan of Queen
very little desire to see it oh it was
kind of the thing to see and then it
wasn't the thing to say it was weird no
I was on the opposite it was that well
it was the thing to see and then it
wasn't the thing to see and then I think
it is the things because they're not the
thing to say no no it sounds like it's
become a worldwide phenomenon the good
really it was I started all over the
world when it wasn't the thing to see
and I was so pleasantly surprised it
wasn't the thing to see I was like yeah
I mean ego in is it's a Hollywood biopic
yeah they're gonna fudge this that in
the other and the details what it's like
that guy's performance I mean imagine
okay you got a play Freddie Mercury
mm-hmm iconic cruise Matic rock star of
all time and it just nail it work on
that I mean he does Wow
well I guess I should see it yes I'm a
huge fan there's a new phenomenon that
one of uh when someone on YouTube
pointed out really funny Lee that
there's a phenomenon of people
pretending they've never heard bohemian
wrap my god oh I thought I'd like the
adults listen on that thing we did oh
yeah oh like people react
yeah people react rose why would they
why would they pretend like they have
never heard us they're getting tons of
views and it's like related to the video
but it's like everybody they go and they
go hater they're like here's a song by
Queen Queen Buffy me Anna rats Odie Gus
Johnson yeah I need a video about it he
said why are they all wideness news
well they yeah so we're gonna throw it
to a quick commercial break that we have
pre-recorded for our convenience over
here you can but we'll be back after
this short commercial break with these
two fine wonderful human beings see you
soon have you finished your holiday
shopping yet well no worries because you
can get everything you need for you and
your loved ones over at me undies you
have never felt a fabric so soft and
luscious before and the good news is
it's gonna hold your genitals one way or
the other
these smooth micro modal three times
softer than cotton is going to be
rubbing up on your genitals and that's
where you want it to be not in a sexual
way but just that you want to take good
care of that part of your body and
you're gonna have fun playful patterns
like this sushi underwear oh you can
take a hey is that a chopstick or my
penis in my case it's hard to tell it
difference it's not as long as the
chopstick but it is as then why stop at
undies Mandy's also has cozy lounge
pants and onesies and socks and the
supersoft fabric perfect for wearing on
Christmas morning guys
Mandy's has got a great offer for our
listeners for any first-time purchases
when you purchase any of my undies you
get 15% off and free shipping order by
December 16th for free shipping and time
for Christmas
are you crunched for time you can't go
wrong with a me undies gift card it's a
no-brainer you're gonna get 15% off you
get the most comfortable underwear you
or anyone you've known has ever worn I'm
telling you that's all I wear now they
get your 50% off your first pair free
shipping and 100% satisfaction
guaranteed head on over to me and ease
calm /h three that's Mandy's calm /h
three then Sarah watches has learned
that luxury is a process it's not about
specs and it's not about price it's not
a marketing term to be thrown around
it's about attention to detail a
step-by-step process to craft every
product is this process that separates
us from the competition them from the
competition
I'm not associated with them they just
pay me to read this it's a belief that
you Eli yes you deserve the best they
are tired of cookie cutter designs and
mass-produced mentalistic watches that
have flooded the market they want to
offer a watch that was able to stand out
get notice get your dick sucked and set
yourself apart rather than conform to
simple design all at an accessible price
they are able to provide the look and
feel of bold luxury watches that are ten
times the price by selling directly to
the customer so the holidays are coming
up guys it's the perfect time to get
yourself or your friends and family a
gift and what's a better gift they meant
Sarah watches get your dick sucked
that's not their [ __ ] I made that up but
it but it could happen
furthermore we are offering to engrave
on the back to create a personalized
message to give a gift that makes the
right statement so go to Vince Sarah
watches dot-com / h3 December and enter
the promo code h3h3 to get 15% off your
entire order Vince er watches dot-com /
h3
December if you're like me you don't
know anything about investing and that's
why Robin Hood is such a great investing
app it lets you buy and sell stocks ETFs
options kryptos all commission-free they
strive to make Financial Services work
for everyone not just the wealthy and
it's a non intimidating way for stock
market newcomers to invest for the first
time with true confidence here's why
it's so great they've got a simple
intuitive clear design with data
presented and then easy to digest way
now I don't know anything about trading
stocks but Dan learned how to trade
using this app and he says that they
have tutorials that show you and kind of
take your hand and tell you what you're
doing so you can learn as you trade is
that right there
that is accurate yeah all right Robin
Hood nope no Commission no fees other
brokers charge up to $10 for every trade
but Robin Hood doesn't charge Commission
fees trade stocks and keep all of your
profits boom learn by doing learn how to
invest as you build your portfolio
discover new stocks and track favorite
companies with personalized news feed
you're gonna get custom notifications
for price movements so you never miss
the right time to invest and now you
want to learn how with a free stock
compliments of Robin Hood they're giving
away a free stock like Apple Ford or
sprint to help build your portfolio
sign up at h3 podcast Robin Hood calm
that's h3 podcast Robin Hood calm and
get a free stock to get started and
learn how's it done there's nothing
better about the holiday season than
unwrapping a brand new phone until you
get hit with that brand new monthly bill
big wireless providers can really suck
the joy out of the holiday so this year
don't just upgrade your phone upgrade
your wireless provider and switch to
mint mobile for a limited time mint
Mobile's offering the best holiday deal
and Wireless you've ever seen three
months of service for only 20 bucks for
limited time guys
mint mould mobiles holiday Deal is here
you get twenty dollars gets you three
months of wireless service of five
gigabytes of 4G LTE data each month plus
unlimited talk and text you're going to
use your own phone with any mint mobile
plan you can keep your old phone number
with all your existing contacts mint
mobile runs on the nation's fastest most
advanced LTE networks and if you're not
100% satisfied mint mobile has you
covered with their seven day money-back
guarantee digital wireless bill and
start saving with mint mobile this is
how it comes they send you a SIM card
you pop it in your phone you're good to
go
these guys I love it so much I love this
product until Internet has gotten way
too expensive
I need a company like this to come
disrupt that's why I love mint mobile
give them a shot guys take advantage of
this mint mobile holiday deal before it
is gone three months of wireless for $20
and get the plan shipped to your door
for Bari by going to mint mobile.com /h
Street that's mint mobile.com /h Street
that's three months of service for just
$20 admin mobile.com /h 3 welcome back
guys so we've got a lot of developments
over the break my parents are listening
and they have some beef with what I said
about embezzling my bar mitzvah line go
ahead they message me pretty much within
a minute of you saying that ask Ethan if
he forgot the Disneyland trip with 20 of
his friends for his Bar Mitzvah stole
his money ha wait I did ok
wow I didn't realize I was paying my own
grateful where there's more there's more
I spent $5,000 on his bar mitzvah and
everything he got which wasn't very much
went into his own baker bank account his
memory is a bit off using his parents
for a laugh shameful there you heard it
from Kyle Gass himself mom Oh mom mom if
I can retort real fast and this is
perfect because you cannot respond yeah
one me you I'm not supposed to pay for
my own bar mitzvah party yeah my madness
is that oh I paid yeah and then the
money in the bank she says I went into
my college fund whatever that that's
what they how do they always say when
they take your money yeah college fund
okay you stole my money well we got a
lot to deal with did you go to college
after all I did did you graduate
barely cuz Jack and I barely graduated
only thing I did was because I went to
UCSC the most forgiving Santa Cruz yeah
the world yeah no grades remember well
they changed that they change them some
classes are still pass no pass but for
the most part you get grades no but
they're very not only liberal in spirit
but also in their forgiveness of the
grading system yeah
learning yeah okay yes was it all
teacher all the professors were hippies
yeah that's what I imagined a whole
Santa Cruz University yes a hacky sack
that's well I will tell you jack that
they had the number-one Ultimate Frisbee
team in the nation that's no joke and
you're right there wasn't one hacky sack
as well on the sidelines that would have
been me I want to see do you have any
video of Frazier falling upstage know
that you asked me that I would love to
see that as these guys were walking in
the god vape is right outside the door
we had the iPad of Kelsey Grammer
falling off stage and so they hadn't
seen this video so I adore this you see
like giving a TED talk here or something
he's giving let's talk about acting
he's very see he's being very serious
and well without further ado enjoy
Kelsey Grammer falls off stage so it's a
small world pretending I was a UN
interpreter
I think
[Music]
and there you have it you want to see
that one more time
my favorite goes oh dear Lord I know cuz
I was laughing on top of the oh dear
Lord I think let's see it again he's
like in character as Frasier have you
ever had any stage malfunctions or any
issues on stage we were recently
watching a collection of artists falling
off stage and there's a lot of it well
occasionally a fan will run up and try
to hug Jack I think that's happened a
couple times don't you remember the one
though where I did have one and I think
it was when we were out on tour with the
Beastie Boys we were doing like a we
were rocking the vote oh they were
rocking the vote and we were just sort
of coming a long time around we were
opening up for the Beasties antenna and
I was like stomping across the stage and
then I just like stomped in between two
big like you can also walk on top of the
big speakers that are out there and I
said like stopped in between speakers
and I went down all the way to my hip no
but the adrenaline bounced me right back
up and I kept on rockin and though
nothing happened and I think that might
have prevented it from going viral was
that I recovered too quickly but it was
pretty intense and I came very close to
breaking my hip one of the great new
member cones and one of the great Falls
we had during a show was our guitar
player and he was shredding he was
shredding an electric guitar solo to the
heavens melting faces and he's walking
back many trips over his just a direct
kind of he had to he had to get right
back up though and continue rocking he
was do we have a videotape we should
might be on YouTube but luckily there's
been no serious injuries on a tenacious
detour that
good and when you fell were you were you
like injured or you work just not to
work I came right back up I was sore and
bruised but now the show must go on and
we had a show the next day I think it
was fun but yeah I felt it the dings and
well there's like there's this one video
of Justin beat like there's just a
straight-up hole yeah on the stage in
this poor guy all right
the Biebs went down the hole yeah let me
show you don't down there in hole and I
feel so bad for him because it's like
what can you do on stage you wearing a
kilt he's wearing a lot of layers I
don't know it's really cold and looks
like it's kind of got an Axl Rose thing
going there yeah yeah so and and so
Bob's your uncle and and bye-bye birdie
[Applause]
we've got the anticipation why would
there be a hole there Hawaii would there
be a home a poor guy I feel so bad you
know like you never had a chance he's
got to get an accident lawyer he's deep
but yet he goes all the way down it's
never quite as serious when you weigh a
hundred and twelve pounds though right
nothing really hurt that's not the
normal stage that had to be like for an
effect or something like wow these
dancers popping up you gotta close the
hole everybody knows to close the hole
everybody knows everybody knows there's
something I heard about you that I found
was interesting or I was thinking about
as you said we we both had this
experience we turned 13 and we said
smell you later
to the Jews yeah but since you've had
kids I've heard that you've returned to
synagogue well I did feel like it was
important for them to feel part of a
community and I wanted them to have that
experience and we did have them enrolled
in a school that had Hebrew studies as
part of the curriculum so it wouldn't
feel like they had to go to extra school
after school hmm
but it wasn't a good fit for the boy we
were there for a few years it's a good
school mm-hmm but um God and actually so
much stress dude is figuring out the
right school for our kids I've spent so
much time and energy and and just like
hmm anxiety over this part I had no idea
being a parent could be so hard let's go
I know public school just what's wrong
with all that well what's wrong with
public cares it doesn't feel like our
society puts enough energy towards
public education well there are so
tragically I feel like even though it's
not fair I feel like I have to use the
resources that that that we have at our
disposal to give our kids the best
possible and
education and that unfortunately does
not include public school at this time
here so and is it a problem for your
kids being it does it cause issues for
them being your son does that ever yeah
that is a factor too interesting it's a
you know when when everybody knows who
your your father is that's kind of a
weird situation for them to be in and
for them to not know if like their
friends or friends because mmm there
yeah that's complicated it's hard enough
for an adult I mean yeah but I think my
boys are relatively well-adjusted and it
was actually my son Sammy who turned me
on to your chef how old is he he's 12
but he's know what a very advanced and a
me thank you saying I always take
Sammy's advice and he's given he's given
me lots of golden nuggets over the years
and Santa and Kyle's always like hey
wait how did you hear about this thing
that we're doing today you've been on
you've been on good mythical morning and
you've been on Hopkins we're both were
those all he needs to be your manager
yeah well I believe this that children
are my glasses have a tendency to fog up
I'm a hot and steamy guy by nature and
sometimes it bothers me and I'll just go
up here for a little while and let him
cool off and I'll bring him back but you
did it kind of without your hands that
was pretty cool yeah well I can bring
him down without my hands I can't get
him get him up there that would be
something business well the reason we've
been thinking about it is because I'm
pregnant
oh really happening have any idea what's
coming out we think yeah
but I don't mind saying we well duh the
person who did the ultrasound
if I had to guess do you they said you
want my guess I was like yeah he says I
love that move and he do it so casually
there wasn't also there's a button on it
did you see that this was a boom look at
that it's like I'm ready for business
yeah Wow what I felt like they were
default enough but I was wrong I
actually need like some sauce and a
cloth because they're they're beyond you
need a defroster like a little fan
inside someone rescue our little our
little troublemaker
the ultrasound guys yes the whole chest
I'll take it yes I'm not sure but uh it
looks like looks like a girl really well
that is not what they said Oh dad they
saw a little tiny little baby penis and
they thought it was a guy but I don't
know I because she's like well
technically the next ultrasound is when
you find out but if you want my opinion
at one angle I saw a little penis which
was kind of another angle your angle I
know what I was looking at huh I mean
the ultra studies early ultrasounds are
so crazy because there's like so much
space and the baby's just like floating
around and she's doing this thing where
she's putting on this pushing on the
stomach and the baby's like like an
eight ball in an eight ball and has
shaken the eight ball and it's like
bouncing around it's crazy it's not yeah
so it's a little boy we think Theodore
yeah you already know you met him how do
you know I feel it yeah yeah I'm fine
I'm great
there it is so we've been wondering what
we would do as far as Jewish the whole
Jewish thing yeah because we're not like
religious right but it is a way of
growing up doing the holidays and also
Spartan they speak Hebrew because you're
family but the extra the extra school is
is just so brutal
I didn't know it's extra because they LT
they don't teach Hebrew at public school
tell you that no sir I felt like there
was something to be gained also from the
the the moral fabric that you get with a
with a with Judaism and just in general
when you have that that cradle of it's a
culture that's a it's an identity and I
very much identify I think I come from
the same you know I'm very much a
cultural Jew you know it is
what is your what's going on with you
what do you are you well I think my mom
tried to cover all the bases
thank I was what he caught when you're
the Christian you get baptized mm-hmm
and she just sort of gonna do that in
there oh that's good so she mutilated my
genitals thanks mom no um yeah I meant
it quickly and then nobody was
interested in in church or anything and
it was just evolved into an atheist
evolved into eight yeah I love that it's
just yeah and uh I gave up
do you regret being circumcised because
that is a debate that goes on today is
that people are angry at their parents
first circle yeah yeah here's one right
here you you why would you do that yeah
we're made we're made fine yeah all the
parts are working fine yeah that whole
like cleaning business is just such a
pile of hooey is it but you don't know
you don't have to miss it
yes you don't remember having I'm gonna
just take a chance on mutilate a
sexually mutilating babies is not a good
idea it's gonna leap of faith there I
mean let's let's not do that it that way
I can do that anytime on my own when I'm
1800 I don't want that foreskin anymore
I think it looks a little nicer oh there
you go aesthetically I can I think in my
opinion I haven't noticed a drop up I
don't have anything compared to but the
quality of our orgasms has been all good
all right baby oh so wait a second maybe
there's something maybe there well do
you know what a lot of people get so
foreskin is complicated business I've
heard a lot of people who
end up having to get their foreskin
removed in their adult life and that can
be one of the most painful I feel like a
circumcision apologist little I am
frankly in about it because yeah the
debate rages on because now we have to
decide if we're gonna do it right really
all these decisions have you asked your
parents what they think about oh I don't
know but I just
I like the exuberance you're a wild man
I say cut it off
I think cut it off but I want to ask you
guys about first of all that HBO show
you guys did is beloved to me still one
of my favorite shows ever
thanks man how do you I mean you guys I
mean it stands the test of time it's
hilarious it was at the time how do you
add tell me about your guys making that
I think that we were ranked like 36 best
HBO show so true Wow well by I think HBO
well it has a hundred percent on Rotten
Tomatoes to this day Wow well how could
you not like so it was like The Sopranos
yeah Game of Thrones yeah something
something the only real question is
where were we ranked in relation to
Flight of the Conchords because that's
our whole oh my god right somehow
compete Oh the new generation of
tenacious dealings you friended those
guys you know those guys yeah we are
friends with them
I think there was a pretend rivalry yeah
right I think I was trying to stoke
those flames not be the greatest thing
it's good for business if you want and
then I think they took it I think he
might have taken it yeah really so well
friendly beef turned to real beef well
in their in their first show they had a
thing a little sort of inside joke we
don't know that this was flight of the
conchords that put this joke into their
episode it could have been an art
director it's such a small thing but
Kyle with his powerful laser scope eyes
noticed that the they had like a
newspaper right is there any
advertisement in a newspaper that
someone's reading hmm in an episode what
does it say it says tenacious Dundee
tenacious d and if you read into that it
finishes is done and we took that very
personally and ever since then and we
love the Conchords a subtler cuter we're
trying to sort of give a vibe like we're
wizards
you've arrived wizard I'd love to see I
think it's in the way sapling the earth
searching there's we're very furry I
love it first no it becomes you what are
furries I think those are good it seems
to be sweeping the nation are being here
let me both this this version is best
presented with photos but for you think
it's for either go to Flaming Lips
concerts nope so this might weird you
out because again people are sensitive
so these are people that dress up as
critters it's a sexual thing though
isn't it far as I know it is a sexual
thing dating other furries they dress up
as critters
they just have orgies really as far as
I'm aware that's I mean correct me if
I'm wrong okay I may be representing
them so Danone he and please fat check
me but it does seem to have a sexual
component yeah it does and I don't know
what's the origin but the faces and I
and I got a cute group there are you
gotta say that's the I think that they
creep me out there is a sexual component
for what I understand I don't know about
orgies happening although I mean explain
this dance yes thank you you but if it's
sexual it's just a dry humping right no
a whole there's like the Mormons
it's gotta be like a velcro flap yeah
but I guess you know I guess it's kind
of nice if you're attract there's a
whole much bunch of them there that's
not and you don't know how but in whose
fights flops closed yeah you don't know
I guess if you're real ugly like you
know myself if you put on a fox outfit
and you show dick and maybe you got a
good one and your face isn't that good
then I'll sign you're like king of the
furries it works to your advantage
right you think that's like 50% of the
reason why people go for it maybe well
you're kind of hiding your identity you
can't really see everyone's kind of
equal interests it's kind of like eyes
wide shut but ridiculous if you have to
adopt a furry voice do that again do you
guys know if they playing aspect so
dancing yes yeah you're going to this
length um you would assume the voice as
well right well I think we should go
undercover well do you paint your dick
red like the red rocket not often Jesus
you know often but Damon
I just looked it up I mean on their
Wikipedia about furries the the sexual
aspect it's fairly far down in the
article there's quite a bit to the
subculture other than the sexual aspect
although I will note that the sexual
aspect that is the biggest part of the
articles so there you go these guys [ __ ]
like crazy I think it's more about the
cuddling really mmm I mean I think
that's what that's about you want to get
snuggly yeah hot and I think all the
first Westerner being like thank you if
their message I hope so you guys created
that show with I didn't know this until
recently David Cross and Bob Odenkirk I
mean what an incredible lineup I'd you
guys get it well they took us under
their their their wing Wow our first
ever show was at a little club that no
longer exists in downtown LA in 94
somewhere around there we played a place
called Al's bar and there was like 12
drunk hipsters in the audience and one
of them was David Cross and he was like
you guys are rad come open for our thing
we do thing called mr. show live and at
clubs in in LA comedy clubs and stuff
and we're like you know yeah let's do it
never heard of them but they they had
come out they had just finished working
with Ben Stiller on the Ben Stiller show
and they they were starting this new
thing called mr. show and and then they
had already made a deal with HBO to have
their show mr. show on the air and they
finagled a way for us to be on HBO to
with short films that they helped us
well correct we were gonna be part of
their show right I remember and it's
like wait a minute these guys don't
really fit into our show they should do
their own little after our show a little
special thing but firstly I remember
they took us to Aspen yeah for the HBO
comedy festival without and that was
very exciting Bob Odenkirk is like has a
recce also kind of
tim and eric' they're big yes Wow which
is just incredible
yeah Bob's a great mentor both of those
guys huge forces in comedy but they're
kind of like under the radar yeah but a
great like well that was great great
advocates for people I find that so
awesome totally it's great to see Bob
just Buster him in this all role I know
the famous for being on better questo
but he was bad before that he was like
Oh Bob I mean he's always doing so many
great things but yeah how was that
watching him have a breakout in like the
Breaking Bad world I mean he's any so
good yeah I think he's just a dramatic
actor now really I mean that he's just
taken in onto that so amazingly and he's
he's getting other parts too left and
right huge roles but I for me it's
always think if that is like a little
side thing that he yeah I don't think of
that as the main part of him the main
part of Bob Odenkirk genius comedic mind
came out of SNL he was one of the
writers staphon on SNL know that just as
a writer and and yeah everything that he
touched seemed to turn to gold he and
and we were really lucky to cross paths
with with him and David Cross they in a
way they owe them everything they gave
us our big break they gave us the big
break yeah so I recommend if you were
trying to break into the industry or in
the 90s and you're trying to break in to
impress Bob and David Jack as I
understand it from a mutual friend of
ours you are also an advocate I have so
I have a surprise why do some what I'm a
surprise oh my god is am I gonna be
surprised by someone from a blast from
my past gonna enter the room I think so
oh no I'm really excited a friend of
mine reached out because he heard you
were gonna be on the show uh-huh and I
don't know that you've seen this he said
but I think that you will be you'll and
be joyed by it
Wow you enjoyed but you will be joined
by it's like this never been joy here we
go tell me if you recognize this oh my
god
it's Justin roiland yeah oh my god
so speaking of genius so Justin roiland
Jack Black helped Justin roiland pitch
and sell his first show as ep Wow Jack
helped Justin get his foot in the door
well Justin reached out and he's like
Jack is amazing he helped me and he
believed in me and I just want to say hi
and thank you and that he loves what a
mensch well let me because you did a
little cameo in this his yeah this is
the first show he ever sold yeah here's
your little cameo which he says the
funniest part of this comes up after
this
this is unaired this is juicy Craig
[Music]
Mitchell this isn't the jingle ewings
time it's a job now get back to work
place that accent god I love eating
maggots out of dead animals I love it I
do it all the time
I'm proud of it too I show it off it
makes me unique um nobody seems to care
that I do it at work either you'd think
they would consider when I work in a
grocery store but they don't let me do
as I please listen to me go on however
and I a character I should get my own
spin-off show I'd be huge
everybody had loved me
[Laughter]
[Music]
there you have it
I forgot that I think was from Lee I
think it was from the early 2000s am i
right but really he had shows coming out
his ears he was creating amazing content
all over the place III don't really
think he that was a stepping stone he
said it was the first show he ever sold
thanks to you you went around why'd you
do with them he he beat it you see him
entry are shown you oh we did a look we
did a little tenacious d thing with
justin roiland time fixers but justin
had tons of people that believed in him
and we're looking for opportunities to
welcome by the way
another photo I want to show you you're
being modest but he this is what he told
me okay
look I couldn't believe he sent me this
photo last night blow doors down well
he's a saver save stuff like that this
is like history I mean this is a
beautiful you know what brought us
together it was all about Dan Harmon and
Rob schrab they do that they did that
thing channel 101 yeah it was a
competitive short film yeah that's how
thing that they did once a month on the
youtubes and yeah all kinds of creative
types like Justin came out of that yeah
but he told me this was at a mr. show he
was just there in the audience and mr.
show yeah and this he just got to meet
you randomly as a fan yeah no those were
the places to be back in 97 you wanted
to be at the tapings of mr. show it felt
like you know they were the Nirvana of
the alt comedy scene thing they at least
see and be seen that's right mmm well
here you have it I love this photo this
I mean this is amazing amazing I gotta
frame this and put it on the wall so uh
that was our two we have questions from
fans oh nice yes we have some questions
from our fans noise
take him live you know we do not take
them life you vet them they were posted
of men are on our subreddit on a fan
forum so let me allow me to read some to
you this one comes from PJ for two for
two
this one's for you jack what was the
Eric Andre interview like did did you
know what you're getting yourself into
and were there any surprises well yeah I
knew what I was getting into in that I'm
a huge fan of Eric Andre and I knew it
was gonna be some sick [ __ ] and I was a
little nervous about it cuz I was like
is he gonna treat me bad but he he it
was what you'd expect it was about a
hundred and twelve degrees on the set by
design to make me uncomfortable
I was sweating profusely it smelled
horrible and then I found out why later
they were broiling hot rodding squid
carcasses underneath the floorboards
also some surprises there's a little bit
of electroshock therapy
every time I we did a lie detector test
in a way it was torture but it was also
like a rite of passage I felt like it
was a late Bar Mitzvah for me if I could
survive the Eric Andre experience and I
loved it it was so funny like the soda
coming or the coffee coming out that was
pure surprise my plan was to try to just
approach it like any other talk show
like I'm going on Conan O'Brien now and
do like a funny little entrance like I
usually do and then just descend into
hell
I recommend it if you get a chance to
embrace the madness that is aircon I
love it and also happy to see you there
this one comes from
incendiary war pig which Tenacious D
song do you guys most enjoy performing
and how many [ __ ] up [ __ ] pushups can
you do today
we love that there was those questions
in there the [ __ ] pushup
yeah and the answer is a real answer if
I is you only need to do one that's
right yeah and you still do one though
I'm afraid I can't I can I can do a
partial but it's like a granny pushup
wait there it has to be from the knees
and I do but I still get there what song
do you like to play the most you know
it's always fun to to to play the crowd
pleasers it's one of the deep cuts that
I enjoy the most I think it is a
Throwdown and it's got its got some
biblical references in there we kind of
go deep yeah and it's about the the
dangers of blindly following organized
religions and about how it could it
could end up being the the end of the
world for all of us the Battle of the
three major you start with Judaism sure
the Moses came down from the hill and
then you go to Jesus and then you go to
the one that you can't state in the song
how do you hurry of the man handling the
three of them and a battling in the rain
the world was completely insane
sound the alarm bombs what was that song
about originally remember we kind of
tweaked a little bit remember oh yeah no
we had the jam for for four months and
we didn't know what the lyrics would be
and then we finally realized this Jam is
so heavy it's important it's an
important job it needs some more
gravitas wait with the big guns we're
going out but what was it about before
that it doesn't matter okay we're clowns
but we do like to get serious sometimes
and maybe that those are the most fun
ones when we tackle real issues you know
yeah well I
that makes me think because I was
watching post-apocalypse
yeah I'm here for me to ask any question
was that sweet petunia I want that dog
but I don't think he's hypoallergenic
yes yeah that's not fur that's like yeah
he gets hair oh my god he's a Yorkshire
Terrier we're hi Shannon
Sammy I bet you if you trust my word at
all are you allergic to dander I'm not
but but the non-shedding is like
beautiful because they're so clean he
literally shares a pillow with us at
night he's so and I have a good place I
can recommend to if you want to get a
similar breed I do
that'd be great they're close by yeah
let's not say that on the air because
then they'll save the puppies yeah I'm
swear I get a rescue do you know how
many dogs need homes
oh this guy needs a home well I'm just
saying I'm just preparing you Kyle's
right there will be some hate mail I'm
back hey how you talk about like you not
get it isn't because I've talked about
it a lot in this because I listen we're
listening thank you now I'm now I feel
stressed that everybody's listening this
dog needs a home yeah what about the
dogs that need be at home yeah yeah all
right you can keep thank you well you
know I love him he's like my son and
more people again you know they're there
other people that are get I crawl into
your heart they did strange and I do
think adopting is a wonderful beautiful
thing but I've got an ultimate hookup of
purebred beautiful paper paper bearing
papers I got about real allergies you
got it you got to be careful yeah so but
you were about to ask us yes my dog
interrupted I was asking because you
were saying you like to get real about
certain things and I was wondering when
I while I was watching post-apocalyptic
do you guys think that we are on the
verge of a apocalypse here is that some
kind of
reaction to something you're seeing in
the world one hopes not sure of course
where one hopes yeah oops not yeah I
mean that that was a that was the
impetus to do post-apocalyptic we felt
like hey this is this is going south
real fast this this guy who's our
the leader of our country is spew and a
lot of hate it's weird it's scary and it
feels like this is what happens right
before some kind of a worldwide
catastrophe this is the kind of talk
that you hear right before World War and
so we were like we need to do
post-apocalyptic to to save the world
that's what we were thinking as we see
we're still here so far well there was a
scene where you guys cut off Donald
Trump Jr's penis no not true or no
you're right it was a you're right you
guys were very delicate about that you
actually got a tremendous BJ he got it
to BJ so good that it was removed from
him or were no no the BJ the BJ is just
like the best BJ of all time and we used
that as the distraction so that we can
get the source of all of his power the
crystal of Gilgamesh right and then we
are discovered yes and then he sends his
attack dogs
he sends Nazis KKK and a demon from hell
of course known as the gorgonzola what's
his name and then spoiler alert I'm not
gonna tell you any more of what happens
then but there is no penis removal oh
but there is
all right his penis is intact there yes
penises penises is well featured in the
episode it does turn into a mushroom
cloud
oh I know we have to watch this again
there's a one dissolve in this feature
film that you guys need to watch is that
when obtained the tip of a penis
dissolves into a mushroom cloud yes Wow
you know the Academy Awards and they're
gonna use that as part of the montage
and of course just a reminder well let
me just borrow your magazine oh no
that tenacious d and post-apocalyptic is
in consideration for best picture it's
just an honor to be nominated yeah it's
an honor to be considered consider
that's all I don't know who took that
out up and thank you considering you
guys but you know we we drew that that
sequence before we even knew that Donald
Trump's penis was shaped like a mushroom
and that was in a way it was like a
Nostradamus moment our imitating life
was it's not senior Oh its life
imitating ripping somebody off yeah
but all the penises were very lovingly
crafted in this series yeah it's
featured in there I don't know why we
talked so much about Elon Musk in that
episode it's just uh well of course you
got a highs if you're talking about
who's gonna survive the apocalypse of
course yeah the super wealthy and the
super ransom genius yeah Engineers will
find a way to it end up on the yeah who
would end up there um you know a big
part of it also when we're making it was
that we felt like we understood the
psychosis that is Donald Trump's the the
the phenomenon that is his astronomic
rise to power because we have a little
seed of his disease - it's called what
is it called Kyle no uh grandiosity
narcissism a narcissistic egotistical
disorder because we we have made our
whole careers on this thing about saying
we're the greatest band in the world
everything flows through us we are the
best man ever and our biggest hit song
was the first song we ever wrote the
greatest song in the world tribute
and so when we see this guy coming out
and go winning I mean the best movement
of we know that scam that he's playing
that Jill but he's not joking that's the
only difference
and and then I and then I started to
think about other people in the industry
who have made a huge career out of this
and you think of like Howard Stern
mm-hmm the king of all media and he's
the best and he's kind of joking but
he's also kind of nice kind of got the
narcissistic looking in the mirror all
the time talking about how Gradius and
then you look around at other people you
see like Kanye West he's the greatest
and he's you know creating and you see
different people in pop culture that
have this disease and are succeeding
because the world in that we live and
now embraces it and they love it they
love a narcissist
and it seems like particular to these
times right now we are vulnerable to
psychos who think they are the greatest
thing people are so accepting of uh just
grandiose the people are like love that
larger-than-life figure is it maybe it's
always been like that but you had said
like today people are more accepting of
it I wonder why that is what do you
think Kyle Kyle knows all the answers to
everything it's true I do
he stole I'm he's trying to think of an
answer which talks about nicotine gum I
think that celebrity is kind of the the
the cachet of modern society it seems
like it's overly valued and I think I
think Donald spent 14 years being
branded over and over again as this kind
of super smart business guy self-made
and I think unfortunately that can
really work and just repetition I mean
there's certain just kind of dynamics at
work that we know that if you just keep
repeating something over and over again
the market yeah you know the marketing
it is like the best marketing campaign
ever mm-hmm so anyway yeah we thought it
would be good
to go flash-forward to the whole world
has been destroyed by this mega maniacal
demon beast and we have to pick up the
pieces because all of the great movies
in in our opinion are the
post-apocalyptic science fiction
masterpieces road warrior a terminator
Wizard of Oz these are the movies I
think we can all agree objectively are
the best movies ever made and they are
warnings they are like look out for the
future
we wanted to jump into that sphere
because not not only because we love
those movies but also because it seemed
like what the world needs now and only a
narcissist could think that they could
save the world and that's where 2d comes
in we are the antidote to the demon
because we are the demon well I don't
know where I'm talking about but it is
where the court jesters sort of pointing
out right exactly well it was very much
like a road warrior rock opera and it's
on YouTube it's at tenacious decom you
should definitely go watch it because
you do maintain so make sure to go link
is in the description by the way we
don't watch it so you can watch it in
episodes you can watch in the movies and
of course make sure to go why don't
everyone just go to tenacious d because
you can get tickets there you can watch
the shows there Canisius decom I should
throw in a caveat apparently it's n
c---seventeen so well there's a couple
of its animated penises economy come on
yeah and I loved it it was hilarious so
guy I think you mean it was such a
pleasure to be here with you guys the
pleasure was mine I mean really we're
all such big fans
what's Kyle doing I just want to get
something very sweet come on you guys
you're not in we're all and I know you
have a lot of latkes to grind there you
thank you for having us yeah thank you
when we play your town lovelyz all right
yeah let's meet your son or if he wants
any like merger okay I don't know
lifetime backstage pass lifetime oh my
god and I just want to if any fans out
there want to see the greatest Tenacious
D show ever
yeah December 30th in Vegas is the one
[Laughter]
[Music]
it's not just my son who loves your show
I have since become a huge fan the
bravery of your honesty I think you guys
really go deep and I and I PKK you keep
up the good work as well thank you guys
that god bless you both god bless god
bless him but or as they say BAE's rut
Hashem guys thank you so much for
watching have a blessed weekend Friday
hey have a awesome time guys will see an
estimate so mom I love you
thanks for the bar mitzvah you guys are
the best
we got a lot to talk about though next
week what do we have on next week is it
Jack and Eric boys out the Jack and Eric
next week that's can't wait so we got it
we're all hooked up we'll see you next
week guys have a great weekend haha
[Music]
you